love this man love his work it's
must-read material every single monday
morning for football morning in america
joining me here once again on nbc sports
on peacock is a hall of famer he is
peter king how are you doing peter
hey rich you know what was really really
fun in my column on monday look i get a
kick out of these kind of football nerdy
things
going back and seeing how cooper cup was
scouted
and finding out from les sneed that his
first encounter
with cooper cup was when he was a camper
at the
peyton manning
at the manning passing academy in sibito
louisiana in 2015. i don't know those
are things that are just so much fun
that
when you're just asking questions and
talking to people you discover little
tiny factoids like that and
it just is a lot of fun that led
the los angeles rams then the st louis
rams that led the los angeles rams in
2017 in sean mcvay's first year to draft
cooper cup anyway no peter i love peter
peter you know one of the things that's
no fun for me this week i love stories
like that peter i mean let's not
forget that uh potentially the mvp for a
fourth time in this league and back to
back in this league
was a quarterback at butte college and
jeff tedford the cal coach went to butte
college to look at a tight end there and
he's like who's this quarterback that's
here and that's how aaron rodgers wound
up at cow and we all know the rest is
history and there's so many stories like
that it's i love them i absolutely love
stories like that you know you know and
how about how about going back to the
guy who preceded him to to brett favre
at southern miss uh
and six weeks before he uh starts his
senior year at southern miss he's in a
horrible car wreck gets 30 inches of in
of his intestine removed oh good uh he's
playing with a bag and he goes to
florida it was at florida state he went
somewhere to some huge school and beat
him and it is you know those are the
kind of things that you sort of remember
when you think about the really great
players that never mind tom brady
lasting to the end of the sixth round
uh
you know behind uh geocarmazi
i mean 100 picks
beyonce for crying i know
everyone's got a story so you mentioned
cup peter where do you stand on the
concept of this
now 17th regular season game
and records that can be broken with a
17th regular season game
you know uh especially i mean i saw the
patriots tweeted out that mac jones set
the the record for
uh touchdown passes by a patriots rookie
breaking jim plunkett's record but
somebody pointed out plunkett did that
in 14 regular season games and and max
done it in 16 with a 17th to boot so
there have been these asterisks for
decades i'm wondering about the newest
one in your estimation peter well
just as
uh
you know when
when roger maris hit his 61st home run
you know to surpass babe ruth
in more than 154 games which is how many
games that babe ruth that was the length
of the season when ruth hit 60.
um
that's just the way a season is now and
mentally you can have an ask asterisk
about it because for 43 seasons the nfl
played 16 games and i think it's beyond
idiotic that they went to a 17th game
when they're always screaming about
player safety uh but be that as it may
whatever a guy gets in a season he got
that in a season
and you can mentally think that
uh
if for some reason
uh cooper cup passes michael thomas or
or whatever records he sets he ought to
ask to risk him but
i mean i'm probably not going to do that
i'm going to make a point that
that's that's just the way it is i mean
there could be 17 games for the next 43
years i doubt it
but there might be and so i just i just
think that's the way
uh that's the way you have to do it
peter king here on the rich eisen show
um i guess i'll use the few good men
phrasing if antonio brown is no longer a
buck
then why hasn't he been cut
so far
what do you make of this peter what's
happening the only thing i can make of
it rich and i've done zero reporting on
this but when i heard about this late
yesterday i said
the bucks are most likely consulting
with the nfl about how to get out of his
contract get out of paying him
um
you know as get out of
trying to trying to pay him the least
amount of money that they can
um
and so
i think it has something to do with that
rich i simply can't believe as as some
have
floated that hey who knows maybe some
desperate team
knowing that
it would only be for three or four weeks
might uh just bring them in for the rest
of this year and i just said man if i
were an owner and my coach said hey i
know this is a terrible idea blah blah
blah but you know we could really use
the help the owner would say you know
let's start with your first sentence
this is a terrible idea and we're not
doing it
i i i hope nobody brings them in antonio
brown needs help not another
uh extension of his football career well
i mean what what coach would do that
though you know what i'm saying because
um
just
look look look at every single coach
i can't think of one but if if for some
reason somebody would have that thought
uh they it needs to be roundly disabused
at the moment of conception of that
thought
peter king here on the rich eisen show
uh what is the brown's plan do you think
for baker mayfield now that we've seen
an absolute step back from last year
with circumstances beyond
baker's control uh we have no idea what
did happen with odell beckham uh we did
see what odell beckham did for the rams
just last week in baltimore
um uh
so what what do you make of baker
mayfield's future and what the browns
plans for him
might be
i don't know what the browns are going
to do with baker mayfield but i can tell
you what
is the only plan to me that makes any
sense and that is
have them play next year it is 18.8
million dollar one-year
uh you know
contract when they exercise the 50-year
option on them
have them play
under that contract for one year
and then
say hey hopefully we'll have a long-term
marriage here but there's no way we can
commit to you
right now um i think it's obvious
that
and if baker mayfield takes that as a
slap in the face that's the way it goes
i mean you just you know play sing for
your supper and we'll see what happens a
year from now i don't know how anybody
andrew berry
jimmy haslam kevin stefanski
could in any way make a serious argument
that hey let's find baker mayfield for
five years and an average of 38 million
a year
and look a lot of this
his play this year might be
because of his injury there's a very
good chance that that's
that's possible but rich in the last six
weeks last six games nine touchdowns ten
interceptions 53 completions
that
is what you would want to extend at a
jillion dollars a year uh
leave me out of that one yeah i guess
you need to see what what happens with
surgery and then move forward but
um
and if he crushes it next year then you
have the ability to franchise tag him
and sign him long term if he wants to
stay there i don't know what the
relationship is there right or do you
what are you hearing about baker with
the browns your relationship i think the
relationship is fine okay i don't think
that is it rich
at all i think it is
that and i'm sure that there are some
things you know that bother him about
whatever has happened in cleveland in
his four years and there's some things
that happen that i'm sure bother the
front office but there's nothing in
there to suggest
any sort of divorce is imminent i just
don't believe it and i just simply feel
right now that
uh that it would be it would be
irresponsible
uh for the browns to pay him like a
franchise quarterback because based on
what we've seen we simply don't know i
think to me the crowning blow was the
game in green bay
that was a game that the browns could
have should have won
as crazy as it sounds but
baker mayfield handed the game to matt
lafleur on a silver platter
and
you know when something like that
happens you just have to say look
there's a chance that this is injury
related but we can't risk the financial
future of this team
on a guy that we're not sure about a few
more minutes left with uh my friend
peter king from nbc sports right here on
nbc sports on peacock serious xm and
also this terrestrial rich eisen show
radio outfit um
much obviously made of big ben's finale
in front of the home folks in pittsburgh
did russell wilson have an old school
three touchdown pass game to dk for
overall big time
game in front of the 12s as a finale
what do you make of what's the future in
seattle
i i don't know rich i think and i hate
to keep saying i don't know but that one
is a weird one because last year at this
time
uh russell wilson was clearly unhappy
about what was going on in seattle i
can't imagine that a
whatever they're going to be six and 11
at whatever their record is going to be
i can't imagine this season has sued
russell wilson's thought about
um playing the rest of his career in
seattle and look uh john schneider
is to me one of the smartest most
progressive
general managers uh who i've ever
covered i think he's really really
bright he's had his misses but they all
have
um and
all i know is that john schneider will
not be afraid whatever the outcome is
he's the guy who
you know
came in and told pete carroll after the
i think 2011 big ten championship in
indianapolis
uh when he out dueled kirk cousins
uh i think he came back into the office
after that and he told pete we got our
quarterback i mean we gotta we gotta go
get russell wilson in the draft next
year
and you know so he's not going to be
afraid
but whatever they decide i think a lot
of it
should be decided by
a frank
conversation
and not one in the media but a frank
conversation between wilson and both
schneider and pete carroll is pete
carroll going to stay
um do they
do the seahawks want him to stay
you know those are the questions that we
just don't know the answers to i know
but if you took your best guess mine
would be
pete stays russell doesn't
what would that be that would be my
guess right
i'm not a big fan of that strategy
you know
i would rather have it be the opposite
because quite frankly
it's a lot harder to find
a top quarterback than it is to
uh get a coach who you can win with
and but you know hey we'll we'll see
what happens and we'll see if
the uh you know we'll see what first of
all we'll see what pete carroll wants i
would assume that pete carroll would
like to stay
he signed for a long time whatever the
next five years
i i would think he would want to stay
and we'll see what what jody allen
really wants to do at the end of this
year and
and then what russell wilson wants to do
in the three minutes i have left with
you peter king um lost amongst
everything that we just discussed and of
course the the passing of the iconic
john madden was the fact that dan reeves
passed away yeah and i'd love to give
you the floor uh on on your favorite
reeve story that might uh lend
uh folks uh an insight into his legacy
in the nfl my favorite dream story is
not a football one but uh
my wife worked at a social welfare
agency in new jersey when i lived in
jersey
and
reeves was the coach of the of the
giants
and dan reeves was a uh
was really really a good person who was
like interested in the whole person
of both of his players and people we
knew and i just happened to mention this
one day and he said hey anything i can
ever do to help that's such a great
thing
um to be helping youth in newark and in
places like that
and i just
i i happened to mention i said what
would you think about if we tried to
auction off a uh a meal for you and
maybe for
um
you know for uh
whoever bids the most
uh for this for this meal and the
benefits will you know the money will go
to this agency and he said i'd love to
do it i'll do it
so we did it we went to a nice italian
place and
near the stadium and uh and the bill
comes and he won't let me pay and he was
magnanimous he was great he was a great
storyteller talking about the ice bowl
and everything and it was great and two
and a half hours later he walked out and
and uh it paid to check himself so he's
just you know a good human being and
rich i'll just say this and i wrote this
in my column i think we at the hall of
fame the voters at the hall of fame
should really try to push for a little
bit of a different way
with people like dan reeves because for
years it's been if you're a coach you're
judged as a coach if you're a player
you're judged as a player so
theoretically dick lebeau could not be
ju he could be judged as one or the
other but not both
which i think is silly
dick lubo's contributions to the nfl go
far beyond his 62 interceptions right
for the lions mostly in the 60s
playing next tonight night train lane
but uh that's how we were supposed to
vote and same with john madden you know
voted only as a coach he's one of the
biggest contributors if not the biggest
in the history of the game so in my
opinion reeves who threw a touchdown
he threw a touchdown pass in the ice
bowl i think it's not only that he won
coach of the year for three different
franchises that he led two different
franchises to the super bowl uh
i think he
has had a very worthy hall of fame
career well said peter king happy new
year to you and yours let's do this uh
very often this next month where all
rubber meets road thanks for the time
sounds great rich take care that's peter
king right here
on the rich eisen show
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here